[Music]
on this Sunday night what did he know
and when the Prime Minister responds to
allegations China tried to interfere in
Canadian democracy but let me be clear a
gunman terrorizes a game night club as I
was dancing on the dance floor I heard
shots fired the horror and the heroes
who put their lives on the line
Deal or No Deal two million Ontario
students learn whether another strike
will cancel classes
and the World Cup kicks off in Qatar
more and more fans have started to show
up the controversy the excitement and
what to expect from Team Canada
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
prime minister Justin Trudeau is on a
plane headed back to Canada after a
10-day overseas trip attending a series
of summits including the G20 where
tensions between Canada and the Chinese
government were in Focus part of the
reason alleged Chinese interference in
our 2019 federal election earlier this
month Global News broke the story that
intelligence officials had warned the PM
in January that China has been allegedly
targeting Canada including funding a
clandestine network of 11 Federal
candidates before he boarded Trudeau
says he was never briefed on that
Mackenzie gray is in Brussels traveling
with the Prime Minister and has more
McKenzie their explosive allegations the
Chinese government attempting to
influence and subvert Canadian democracy
and today the Prime Minister responded
to what he knew about those allegations
Global News was the first report in
January 2022 Canadian intelligence
officials delivered a series of
sensitive memos and briefs to warn the
Prime Minister and select members of his
cabinet that ceases had evidence China
ran a sophisticated scheme to influence
the 2019 election these memos detailed a
large covert transfer of funds directed
by officials in China's Toronto
consulate to members of the alleged
Network including a federal campaign
staffer and provincial politician
according to the intelligence briefs
however today Judo said he doesn't know
the at least 11 Federal candidates
alleged to be a part of the PCR
interference ring according to
information obtained by global news nor
if they receive funds from China
I do not have any information nor have I
been briefed
on any federal candidates receiving any
money from China Global News has
reported the 11 candidates were part of
the alleged network but there is no
evidence that Chinese officials ever
directly funded their campaign
Trudeau is less clear when pushed on
what other possible briefings or
information he had received on the
alleged Chinese interference in the 2019
election so just to be clear sir you
learned about this all these allegations
when Global News first reported it
um
these media reports were things that we
took seriously and we asked our security
officials to follow up on them and we
have asked them to give all information
that they can to share what they can
with the Parliamentary committee looking
into it but again let me be very clear
I have no information and I get briefed
up regularly
from our intelligence and security
officials I have no information on any
federal candidates receiving money from
China
sources have told Global News the Prime
Minister was given both in-person and
written briefing stating that the
alleged Chinese clandestine election
interference Network in 2019 included at
least 11 candidates and 13 staff but
those candidates were not named some but
not all of the candidates and staff were
witting Affiliates of the Chinese
Communist Party the intelligence memos
allege according to information obtained
by global news the Prime Minister says
he's directed intelligence officials to
give any information on alleged Chinese
interference to the procedure and house
Affairs committee which will probe this
issue but he has yet to say whether
he'll testify at the committee like
they've requested pharah
Mackenzie gray and Brussels thank you
Mackenzie
parents and students across Ontario have
been on pins and Eels this weekend
anxiously waiting to find out if school
will go ahead tomorrow the union
representing 55 000 education workers
and the provincial government had until
5 PM Eastern today to negotiate a deal
to stop another strike our Mike troulet
has been tracking this and Mike it looks
like they did it
yes for a potential crisis has been
averted here in Ontario with a
last-second deal that will keep teachers
in the classroom the Santa Claus Parade
ran by here earlier today with thousands
of parents and their and their kids
lining the streets gritting their teeth
possibly because of the coal but also
the uncertainty over the fact that there
is a potential for 55 000 School
teachers in this province to go on
strike there was a 5 PM deadline set by
the union to get a deal and it came went
right down to the wire the sticking
points were money The Province had
agreed to 15 pay raise over four years
and uh and the other issue was workers
which The Province barked at hiring more
assistance more eces more janitors more
secretaries we're unsure if that is in
the new deal but for now we can tell you
that a last-minute deal has been reached
and ending this hopefully ending this
contentious and nasty bitter fight one
last point though today QP did link to
the PC website it's Premier Doug Ford's
birthday his 50th birthday today and
they suggested that its members send him
birthday wishes he might not want to
look at those too closely pharah back to
you
Mike drulay in Toronto thank you Mike
what was supposed to be a fun Saturday
night out has turned into America's
latest deadly mass shooting a gunman
opened fire at a gay nightclub in
Colorado killing at least five people
and injuring 18 others a memorial has
now been set up outside the club in the
City of Colorado Springs where mourners
have been leaving flowers next to a sign
that says love over hate one man is now
in custody Jennifer Johnson has one
bartender's first-hand account and why
some Club goers are being called Heroes
the deadly shootings happened just
before midnight at the club Q patrons
desperately tried to escape as the lone
gunman carrying a long rifle opened fire
it was so scary I heard shots broken
glass bodies
bartender Michael Anderson thought he
was going to die what I can't stop
thinking about is the visuals of the
evening of of of the bodies of the blood
and seeing a safe place turned into a
war zone police arrived quickly and
apprehended the suspect in just over
five minutes after the first emergency
call they say the suspect 22 year old
Anderson Lee Aldrich entered the club
and immediately began shooting but
patrons risked their own lives to stop
him at least two heroic people inside
the club confronted and fought with the
suspect and were able to stop the
suspect from continuing to kill the FBI
has joined the investigation the
shooter's motive hasn't been determined
but investigators are looking into
whether this was a hate crime
prosecutors are promising Justice will
be served actions taken to strike fear
in specific communities will not be
tolerated in our community Colorado has
been the site of some of America's most
notorious mass shootings including
Columbine High School in 1999 an Aurora
movie theater in 2012 and a boulder
grocery store last year this city has
headed Sheriff Mass violence too
Colorado Springs is once again in
mourning our hearts go out to the
victims
and their families who are bearing the
weight of this horrific tragedy for the
lgbtq community this tragic event brings
back Nightmares of the Orlando Pulse
Nightclub shooting in 2016 that left 49
Club goers dead the Club Q Massacre was
America's sixth mass shooting in
November alone another city trying to
make sense of such a senseless act
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
China is sticking with its zero coven
strategy despite public outcry the
government's determined to wipe out
infections through lockdowns quarantines
and mass testing cases there are surging
though today China reported its first
death from covid-19 in nearly six months
the victim is an 87 year old man from
Beijing where more strict measures are
again being imposed people there and in
other cities with Rising cases are being
told to stay at home
world leader is at the cop 27 climate
Summit in Egypt have finally reached a
deal to help smaller Nations bearing the
brunt of the climate crisis
after days of tense negotiations that
almost collapsed nearly 200 countries
have agreed to create a loss and damage
fund it will compensate poorer nations
with a smaller carbon footprint that
have been battered by climate disasters
the summit fell short of any new
commitments on phasing out fossil fuels
or cutting back Global emissions
the cleanup's only just begun in Buffalo
New York from that monster snowstorm
there
people are digging out after almost two
meters of snow blanketed Buffalo and
surrounding cities blowing snow is still
pounding other parts of Western New York
state but the worst seems to be over the
historic Lake Effect snowstorm created
Chaos on the roads and it's linked to at
least three deaths
Donald Trump is snubbing Twitter
coming up why the former president is
saying thanks but no thanks to Elon Musk
plus Happy Birthday Mr President the
age-old question Joe Biden is now facing
the green party has two new leaders
tonight and one is a very familiar face
Elizabeth May will take the helm again
but this time she will co-lead the party
with Jonathan pedno a former human
rights worker the pair won yesterday's
leadership race succeeding enemy Paul
who resigned last year after a
tumultuous tenure that only lasted 10
months May led the greens from 2006
before she stepped down in 2019.
the emergencies act inquiry is heading
into the home stretch for the past few
weeks more than 60 Witnesses have
testified offering their thoughts on
whether the federal government
overstepped by invoking the ACT to stop
the Convoy protests the crippled Ottawa
Archie political correspondent David
Aiken gives us a recap of the key
testimonies and looks ahead to this week
when the PM will be in the hot seat
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act prime
minister Justin Trudeau knew his
government was making a controversial
decision last winter giving law
enforcement agencies sweeping never
before used powers
to clear protests in Ottawa and
elsewhere that had started as
anti-vaccine mandate demonstrations but
had morphed into something bigger and in
the view of some officials something
more dangerous the convoys were feeding
off of each other
uh that they were causing significant
economic
um
instability
that the violent rhetoric was increasing
um rapidly and
um exponentially as the prime minister's
National Security adviser Jody Thomas
was one of the most influential voices
advising cabinet to invoke the ACT she
testified at the commission that that
was the right call we needed to take
Swift and decisive action to bring this
National crisis to an end but her view
is not shared by all
the Ontario Provincial Police for
example said the protest could have been
cleared without either of the federal or
provincial emergencies acts in my humble
opinion we would have reached the same
solution with the plan that we had
without either of those pieces of
legislation evidence has emerged that
our CMP commissioner Brenda lucky
thought invocation of the federal act
was premature that not all tools in the
toolbox as she put it had been used that
said she testified that the powers given
police did help those authorities ended
up to be useful with the plan protesters
themselves have been commission
Witnesses and not surprisingly they
think the Trudeau government overreached
I had never had an agenda I literally
just wanted to help some truckers drive
across Canada and stand in front of
parliament with some signs that was
literally what I had envisioned the
first politician to testify at the
commission this week will be Bill Blair
he's the former Toronto police Chief who
is the Minister of emergency
preparedness
he will be one of eight cabinet
ministers including the Prime Minister
who will take the witness stand before
the commission renders its verdict and
it's a verdict it must give to the House
of Commons no later than February the
20th pharah
David Akin and Ottawa thank you David
Twitter's new owner Elon Musk says he
will reinstate Donald Trump's Twitter
accounts but the former U.S president
says he's not interested the snub comes
after a Twitter poll by musk showing the
majority was in favor of Trump's return
Trump was banned from the social media
site for inciting violence two days
after his supporters stormed the U.S
Capitol Trump says he'll be sticking
with his own platform truth social
[Music]
the World Cup kicks off in Qatar ahead
the ugliness marring the beautiful game
[Music]
today was the day soccer fans around the
world have waited for the 2022 FIFA
World Cup has finally kicked off in
Qatar with much excitement though not
everyone feels the same way
the controversial host nation has been
widely condemned for its poor human
rights record and its harsh laws against
lgbtq plus people there are also reports
thousands of Migrant workers have died
preparing for the games in response many
pubs in Germany are boycotting the
competition they won't show any matches
and popular musicians like Dua Lipa and
Shakira have refused to perform for the
competition
now despite all the criticism soccer's
biggest tournament will go on and fans
still have a lot to watch for especially
as the Canadian men's soccer team makes
its first appearance at the World Cup in
more than 30 years Joshua cloak a writer
from the athletic has been following the
team very closely in fact he just
released a book about them called the
voyagers I spoke with Joshua earlier
today as he reports on the ground from
Qatar
I know you just came back from practice
and we're going to talk about that in
just a sec Joshua but first I want to
ask you I mean given all the
controversies surrounding This World Cup
in particular what's the moon like on
the ground
yeah I would say the mood is kind of
changing day to day I mean I've been
here for about a week now and and you
know as of last week you probably
outside of the signage uh which is
everywhere you wouldn't know that
there's a World Cup here but just day by
day more and more fans have started to
show up
um you know you can't walk throughout
the which is the big Market here the big
outdoor market and not see pockets of
fans you know pockets of fans from
Senegal chanting pockets of fans from
Mexico walking and chanting
um so slowly I would say day by day it's
starting to feel more and more like in
World Cup obviously you know with
today's first match
um it's it's obviously here it's it's
very much here but in terms of the mood
and the controversies surrounding this
world cup look you can't have a
conversation without a fellow journalist
here without you know talking about it
and I think that's that's completely
normal but um you know I guess as more
and more games happen today there was
just one game but as we get to the point
where there's multiple sometimes four
games a day it will certainly feel like
a proper World Cup and I think
anticipation then will start to grow and
grow
well anticipation is building for
Canadian fans I know as I mentioned you
just came back from practice are are
Canadians men's players ready
I would think they're more than ready
right they're one of the last teams to
kick off they don't kick off until the
23rd and when they do they play Belgium
which is literally one of the best teams
on the planet what's interesting about
this Men's National Team you know it is
their first World Cup in 36 years and a
lot of times when teams go to the World
Cup either for the first time or the
first time in a long time they have very
very kind of tempered expectations this
Canadian team they finished top of the
group in concacaf they believe they can
compete and make some real noise here I
asked Jonathan David you know Canada is
a Star Striker I said can you beat
Belgium and the first words out of his
mouth were of course
um and you know his rationale was on any
given day any team can beat any other
team so I would think it's fair to call
this Canadian team very confident right
now they were you know bolstered by the
addition of Alfonso Davies who arrived
with the Men's National Team a few days
ago after staying in Munich to continue
to rehab an injury so yeah I would think
confidence is very very high within this
Men's National Team right now Joshua
from the athletic joining us from cutter
thanks Joshua thank you
and from the World Cup to the gray cup
Regina is buzzing with CFL fans tonight
as the Toronto Argonauts battle the
Winnipeg Blue Bombers for this year's
championship
it's great to be rubbing the bombers
here but nobody puts on a party like
Prairie Folk
s crowds have taken over Saskatchewan's
Capital where there's fear support for
the Rough Riders who missed out on this
year's final Winnipeg one in 2019 and
2021 2020 was canceled because of the
pandemic Toronto won the cup in 2017.
next Joe Biden celebrates a milestone
birthday and breaks a record as his
critics ask how old is too old to be
president
[Music]
it's been a busy weekend for the
American president but not because of
work Joe Biden's granddaughter got
married yesterday at the White House and
the family is gathering again today for
another celebration his birthday and
it's a milestone Biden is now the first
sitting U.S president to turn 80. as
Mike Armstrong reports critics wonder if
the oldest commander-in-chief is tooled
well it's good for all of us to be
together Joe Biden is now with this
birthday 16 years past his life
expectancy when he was born in 1942
American men were supposed to live on
average to just 66 years old now 80
Biden has said it's totally legitimate
for voters to question his age although
some of his fellow octogenarians find it
offensive I think the the satire about
him and the sneering at him is ages he
doesn't appear confused at all to me as
I've read he seems fine whatever they'd
want to do a 21 year old you want to get
a gen Zia
well politics are a popularity contest
and Biden has to convince voters he's
got the Vitality for the job there's a
reason he tends to do that little
jogging move for politicians around the
older side of the spectrum they do have
to be able to persuade voters that they
can do the day-to-day work that they
have the energy and the capacities hi
Joseph well that was a challenge for
Biden two years ago when he was elected
at 77. it's going to be a bigger
challenge two years from now if he runs
again at 82. a recent poll found 70
percent of Americans think Biden is too
old to work in government I am concerned
that someone well into their mid-80s
serve as presidents I mean I can't think
of a more demanding job you know as a
nation health-wise some experts have
called Biden a super Ager it's a term
for someone who stays healthy and
efficient into their 80s and 90s he
still exercises and the medical records
that have been released are positive but
Biden today isn't quite the Biden of
just a few years ago his gate is lower
he is a little more hunched over so he's
showing his age good Biden has said
he'll speak to his family over the
holidays about whether to run for a
second term he'll announce his plans
early next year but for now there's no
big birthday celebrations just a family
brunch some have said so as not to
remind the voting public just how old he
is Mike Armstrong Global News
one man who will never step aside is
Santa Claus and today a long-standing
tradition was held in his honor foreign
[Music]
Hiatus the Santa Claus Parade returned
to the streets of downtown Toronto it's
Canada's longest running Santa Claus
Parade which started in 1905. that's
global national for this Sunday night on
behalf of our entire crew thanks so much
for spending part of your evening with
us Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]